todas las cifras son inquietantes la
tasa de fertilidad está en el 1,16 Pero
en algunas ciudades baja del uno los
nacimientos caerán por primera vez por
debajo del umbral psicológico de los 10
millones el resultado es que la
población china empezará a encogerse el
año que viene sin aprobó en 1980 la ley
del hijo único En aquellos tiempos el
país no tenía muchos recursos la tasa de
fertilidad era altísima y estaba un
fresco El recuerdo de las hambrunas del
Gran salto adelante la ley cumplió con
su cometido pero los expertos ya
advirtieron de que Tendría que haber
sido jubilada mucho antes del 2015 para
entonces los efectos colaterales eran ya
excesivos especialmente el
envejecimiento de la población que
convierte a China en un caso único es el
primer país que la sufre sin haber
alcanzado el pleno desarrollo los
efectos para la economía podrían ser
devastadores Hablamos de una
insuficiente mano de obra o de la
presión tremenda para el sistema de pe
se habla de la pirámide invertido lo que
es lo mismo que cada chino tenga que
mantener a dos padres y cuatro abuelos
el gobierno ha incentivado la natalidad
con ayudas económicas y con bajas de
maternidad pero las parejas jóvenes no
están por la labor operan por un lado
las mismas razones que en occidente es
decir la Eucaristía de la vida o las
ganas de disfrutarla sin excesivas
ataduras y por el otro una razón que
podríamos denominar china es la extrema
competitividad de esta sociedad y que
empuja a muchos padres a dirigir todos
sus recursos económicos hacia un solo
hijo para asegurar su éxito